Prince Harry's Memoir spare is the
latest release from the Duke and Duchess
of sussex's vast portfolio of shows
podcasts and books after stepping down
as working members of the British royal
family in 2020 no longer paid to
represent the crown the couple have
explored new income streams as the next
chapter of their lives unfolds
here's what we do and don't know about
how Harry and Megan make their money
Harry are you putting money before
family are you putting money before
family
in Spare the title and Nod to having an
heir and a spare to the throne Prince
Harry speaks about topics ranging from
physical locations with his brother
William to losing his virginity to an
older woman behind a pub the couple
signed a book deal with penguin Random
House widely reported to be worth 20
million dollars which includes the
headline gramming Memoir I called my
Publishers up right away and said put me
on the list story is interesting because
it keeps evolving I'm sure it's
partially
do to a lifestyle that they want and
what can they sell on the day of its
release spare was at the top of Amazon's
best sellers list alongside the book
deal there are multi-year agreements
with Netflix and Spotify reported to be
worth roughly 120 million dollars
Harry and Megan will make content for
the two platforms through divisions of
their R-12 organization their first
offering for Netflix a six-part
documentary series had the streaming
service's biggest debut for a
documentary Title by hours viewed the
company said we all have greatness
within us Harry also has a job at the
Silicon Valley startup better up as
Chief impact officer his compensation
package was not disclosed but jobs with
that title boast an average salary of
140 000 according to talent.com
the Duke and Duchess also received an
unknown but substantial son from Harry's
father according to a spokesperson
altogether that would total a lot more
than the sum they received from the then
Prince Charles in 2020. financial
releases from his estate reveal the
sussexes along with William and Kate
shared around 5.4 million dollars to
fund their activities now Harry and
Megan have security costs and living
expenses to worry about they live in
Montecito California where they bought a
home for over 14 million dollars and
there was the small task of paying the
crown back the estimated 3 million
dollars it cost to renovate Frogmore
Cottage in Windsor
Harry and Megan lived there after they
were married until they moved to the U.S
leaving the family business so to speak
has opened up a world of new
opportunities for the couple but their
sources of revenue are less secure at
least King Charles III has a guaranteed
income from his property Estates and
Public Funding representatives for the
Duke and Duchess didn't immediately
respond to a request for comment it is
possible Harry and Megan will need to
continue making commercial deals to
sustain their lifestyle
[Music]